the gyro can experience but there's a
generation of people putting luminol on
people's online history that that will
die out and and it'll turn into if it
was something horrible a week ago yes
let's talk about that if you dug up
something someone did ten years ago
everyone's gonna go yeah you should see
this [ __ ] I but like that won't that
won't land the way that it is now yeah I
think our expectations of people are
different we don't we're not under the
illusion anymore that these aren't real
people because we want them to be
presidential or we want them to be
represented we're not under the illusion
anymore that they that are that they're
not real people it's almost like when
they had to admit that WWE was fake it's
like okay now we could just enjoy it for
what it is you don't have to have these
arguments with your friends over whether
or not it's fake you know think about
the WWE that everyone keeps um
forgetting is yes it's scripted but it's
scripted mayhem and destruction they are
scripting out these people these men and
women going in the script you're going
to fall forty feet onto a table of glass
yes we scripted that to happen but it's
still a person doing that yes like
there's a level of adrenaline junkie 'no
status ism that goes beyond i think
athletics yeah some people like you know
wrestling's fake yeah no [ __ ] these
people it's like when you watch a Jackie
Chan film that descripted film to stick
around for the end credits he just got
his skull knocked open
yeah they literally punched a hole
through his skull doing a stunt so
you're you're you're dismissing
something your definition of fake needs
to be tweaked a little bit in this case
yeah it's another way of looking at it
it's it's it's definitely it's
definitely scripted it's not like
they're risking it all because they
don't know what the outcomes gonna be
it's different than an actual athletic
event but it's still pretty badass like
as far as what they're able to do I mean
yes they don't get nearly enough credit
for it either because while they were
doing it before the the lockdown if they
were doing it 250 plus days a year
traveling all over the country
each other on tables different timezones
a bad jet lag bad food no direct no
sleep like these people that have to be
in peak physical condition under the
worst conditions to maintain that yeah
and and also think of the years when the
WWE was this struggling basically
mom-and-pop operation trying to launch
itself and they had even less resources
than they do now and but those guys were
still doing that over and over and over
again it's brutal and Mme is the same
way those guys there's no money there's
the travels brutal that make like the
amount of mattress they have to do is
brutal omma yeah yeah it's uh it's all
brutal
[Applause]